breaking out overnight an admission from
the Iranian government's after days of
denials and under mounting international
pressure the country now says its armed
forces unintentionally shot down a
Ukrainian jetliner this week killing
everyone on that flight at a briefing
this morning the head of Iran's air
defenses said Iran's military was on
high alert due to Iran's confrontation
with the United States and mistook the
plane for a hostile target Holly
Williams is in Baghdad this morning
Holly good morning good morning Iran's
president Hassan rouhani finally
admitted this morning local time that
his country was responsible for downing
the plane CBS News found scavengers at
what is believed to be the crash site
yesterday picking over what's left of
this disaster two days after the
commercial jet was downed by Iranian
missiles and the site cleaned up by
Iran's investigators iran's Foreign
Minister Javad Zarif expressed profound
regrets apologies and condolences but
also seemed to lay part of the blame on
the United States saying the human era
came at a time of crisis caused by u.s.
adventurism Iran's military says the
plane was mistaken for a hostile target
the missile strikes targeting US forces
here in Iraq were a revenge attack after
President Trump's decision to
assassinate one of Iran's top generals
Qasem Soleimani he was killed by a drone
strike in Baghdad last week US
satellites detected two surface-to-air
missiles hitting the Boeing 737 just
after takeoff bringing down Ukrainian
Air Lines flight 752 this video is
believed to show the plane exploding the
wreckage has been moved to Tehran's
airport where ukrainian investigators
have begun to examine them Iran says it
will share the contents of the black
boxes Iran has pleaded guilty said
Ukraine's President Vladimir Lenski in a
statement but also demanded that those
responsible be brought to justice
payment of compensation and apologies
through diplomatic channels
hamed s million lost his young daughter
and wife parisa who posted this selfie
just before takeoff we had we had a very
very good life and you know I appreciate
that but I think he was not right I
think it was not fair what happened the
terrible irony is that Iran's missiles
caused no casualties here in Iraq
there's even been speculation that Iran
deliberately missed American forces in
order to prevent a further escalation
with the u.s. Dana all right Holly thank
you
you